- [Instructor] We are asked,
what is the critical value
t star or t asterisk for constructing
a 98% confidence interval for a mean
from a sample size of n is
equal to 15 observations?
So just as a reminder
of what's going on here,
you have some population,
there's a parameter here,
let's say it's the population mean,
we do not know what this
is so we take a sample.
Here, we're gonna take a sample of 15.
So n is equal to 15.
And from that sample, we
can calculate a sample mean.
But we also wanna construct
a 98% confidence interval
about that sample mean.
So we're gonna go take that sample mean
and we're gonna go plus or
minus some margin of error.
Now in other videos, we have talked about
that we wanna use the t distribution here
because we don't want to
underestimate the margin of error.
So it's going to be t star
times the sample standard deviation
divided by the square
root of our sample size
which in this case was going to be 15,
so square root of n.
But what they're asking us is well
what is the appropriate critical value?
What is the t star that we
should use in this situation?
And so we're about to look at a,
as you would call it, a t
table instead of a z table.
But the key thing to realize
is there's one extra variable
to take into consideration
when we're looking up the
appropriate critical value
on a t table and that's this
notion of degree of freedom.
Sometimes it's abbreviated df.
And I'm not gonna go in
depth on degrees of freedom.
It's actually a pretty deep concept.
But it's this idea that you actually have
a different t distribution
depending on the different sample sizes.
Depending on the degrees of freedom.
And your degree of freedom is going to be
your sample size minus one.
So in this situation,
our degree of freedom
is going to be 15 minus one.
So in this situation,
our degree of freedom
is going to be equal to 14.
And this isn't the first
time that we have seen this.
We talked a little bit
about degrees of freedom
when we first talked about
sample standard deviations
and how to have an unbiased estimate
for the population standard deviation.
And in future videos, we're going
to more advanced conversations
about degrees of freedom.
But for the purposes of this example,
you need to know that when
you're look at the t distribution
for a given degree of freedom,
your degree of freedom is
based on this sample size,
and it's going to be your
sample size minus one
when we're thinking about
a confidence interval
for your mean.
So now let's look at the t table.
So we want a 98% confidence interval
and we want a degree of freedom of 14.
So let's get our t table out
and I actually copy and
pasted this bottom part,
moved it up so you can
see the whole thing here.
And what's useful about this t table is
they actually give our confidence
levels right over here.
So if you want a confidence level of 98%,
you're going to look at this column,
you're gonna look at this
column right over here.
Another way of thinking about
a confidence level of 98%,
if you have a confidence level of 98%,
that means you're leaving 1%
unfilled in at either end of the tail
and so if you're looking
at your t distribution
everything up to including that top 1%,
you would look for a
tail probability of 0.01
which is, you can't see
it right over there,
let me do it in a slightly brighter color,
which would be that tail
probability to the right.
But either way, we're in
this column right over here,
we have a confidence level of 98%.
And remember, our degree
of freedom here is
we have 14 degrees of freedom and so,
we'll look at this row right over here,
and so there you have it,
this is our critical t value, 2.624.
Let's just go back over here.
And so there you have it,
we have 2.624 is our answer.